[Musique]
en mai 2000 20 41 élèves de quatre
établissements de l'île et s'envoleront
pour le népal afin d'escalader un sommet
de cinq mille mètres au nord est de
katmandou en direction du tibet un
projet à la fois humanitaire culturel et
sportif porté par thierry renard
professeur d'éducation physique et
sportive
pour financer ce voyage plusieurs
actions était mise en place de nombreux
partenaires soutiennent également le
projet tel que le département
on est venu ici parce que le rapport au
milieu naturel est un lien avec le trek
elle va faire puisque ans l'ascension il
ya effectivement il n'y aura pas
d'escaladé en propre en dessert en
termes de matériel en dehors de ça va
être du trek mais en même temps tout le
lien du sens de l'effort la
concentration la solidarité la sécurité
tout ça sont des liens que l'on peut
faire entre que ce soit du trait camp
nou où que ce soit dans une activité ce
qu alan qui est peut-être un peu plus
pointu un peu plus technique mais le
lien et le lien et le même fait en
termes de sécurité d'efforts et de
respect des règles de sécurité
le collège antoine soubou fera des dons
de lunettes à la population népalaise
car le projet appelle chaque groupe
scolaire intégrer une dimension humaine
leur ce voyage des jeunes qui mesure la
chance qui disons d'effectuer une telle
expédition une chance parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui peuvent aller
au népal ouais ça représente beaucoup
parce que d'abord un projet humanitaire
donc c'est pour aider les gens donc
forcément ça me fait plaisir
de faire plaisir aux gens ça représente
aussi beaucoup d'investigations de
beaucoup s'investir dedans si on vient
une fois sur deux ans hachage ou autre
action pour préparer le projet bas ça
sert à rien enfin bon c'est pas le
projet pour partir on fait pour aider
les autres et et pour s'aider soi-même
pour parce qu'on peut découvrir des
choses sur nous même en partant là bas
avec le manque de confort on peut on
peut voir nos limites qu'on peut
dépasser en dans la difficulté des
épreuves et des choses qu'on va pouvoir
traverser grâce à l'escalette qu'on se
connaît et qu'on s'entend bien
ça nous prépare à l'aboutissement d'un
projet aux multiples facettes mise en
place depuis trois ans
[Musique]